damien cantat enchaîne les livraisons
malgré un mois de janvier très doux la
demande de fioul ne faiblit pas chaque
jour de nouvelles cuves à remplir pour
nous c'est le plein boom en os lire
l'hiver c'est c ou qu'on livre le plus
surtout les particuliers après l'été
c'est plus les paysans après on n'est
jamais en ai jamais arrêté royal
jeanine le creux gare de la maison d'une
amie aujourd'hui elle a repris 500
litres 445 euros à renouveler
régulièrement pour tenir un hiver
complet pour personnes âgées faut
compter deux mille litres
parce que ces 500 à chaque fois et
niveau m'a quatre fois le chauffage un
coût non négligeable pour les
particuliers
d'autant que les tarifs de l'électricité
ou des énergies fossiles ou augmenter
début 2018
les tarifs de toutes les énergies ont
augmenté en janvier
le fioul comme le reste donc on est on
se retrouve toujours à égalité et
voilà ce sont des taxes qui sont arrivés
donc pour tout le monde
alternative qui se développent le
chauffage au bois xavier collin vient de
s'installer à cosne sur loire pour ce
négociant dans un département forestier
comme la nièvre le bois est largement
compétitif on est sur des bases de
l'après livré à 50 euros ttc le ster en
mode 50 voilà sachant qu'un ménage lui
il faut à peu près une dizaine de stères
par parents pour chauffer su qu'un
insert ou un poil ce qui fait à peu près
un coût relativement modeste par rapport
au chauffage traditionnel swatch ou
l'électricité
on sera à peu près 5 à 600 euros dans
des maisons bien isolées quoi
si les réserves sont faites à l'automne
les livraisons continuent tout l'hiver
d'autant que le froid est de retour au
moins jusqu'en fin de semaine prochaine